un groupe d'enfants a mené la marche à
la mémoire de Maria 7 ans celle qui
fréquentait leur école primaire avant
d'être appelé mortellement par une
voiture mardi derrière eux des parents
et des voisins endeuillés ils ont marché
sur la rue Rouen jusqu'à l'intersection
partenaire pour se recueillir sur les
lieux de la tragédie au coin de la rue
une montagne de cadeau et de souvenirs
j'ose pas imaginer comment la famille
doit sentir en ce moment
on espère que on espère leur apporter un
peu réconfort en tout cas car le
Saint-Denis s'implique dans son quartier
il a fondé en 2020 le collectif
apaisement pour Sainte-Marie c'est une
question de temps il y a des gens qui
disent il va falloir attendre que
quelqu'un décide pour qu'on passe à
l'action ça a été dit là je rapporte des
paroles qui ont été dites parmi voisins
la mairesse de Montréal Valérie plante a
participé à la marche elle a promis
d'accélérer les interventions pour
protéger les piétons comme avec l'Inst
de dollars la tragédie est assez
produite puis on voulait envoyer un
message clair qu'on va continuer puis on
va augmenter la cadence pour sécuriser
et j'ai envie de vous dire le secteur
elle invite également la population à
une réflexion plus large sur la place
des voitures en ville faut que les
automobilistes les gens il faut que les
gens se responsabilisent envers les plus
vulnérables à route mais les paroles ne
suffisent plus selon un résident de la
rue Rouen il veut des solutions depuis 5
ans il a souvent contacté la ville pour
porter plainte mais les retours d'appels
se font rares l'un de ces exemples là
c'est le panneau de vitesse ici là oui
oui le panneau de vitesse ça fait au
moins un an qu'il ne fonctionne pas j'ai
averti la ville et il y a rien qui s'est
faite à un an malgré tout les résidents
que nous avons rencontrés ne perdent pas
espoir il n'oublieront pas la jeune
Maria ici Alexis Tremblay Radio-Canada à